Leslie Jones has been absolutely
bombarded lately with a series of racist
and despicable tweets Paul Feig and
Katie Dippold have both been tweeting
their support for Leslie we want to ask
you what what do you admire most about
Leslie strengths well first of all she's
a great writer great comedian and just
just and comes from a real urban
background where she had a lot of
hardship and she's channeling that into
a great achievement in a great career
and anybody that's these people first of
all they're insignificant gnats they're
losers they they have no lives of their
own they can probably bury very barely
pay for the WHI fire they're using you
probably know jobs I would say you're
looking at you know you're looking at
obese white men between 50 and 60 who
are active Klan members or members the
Aryan Nation and there are millions of
them and I'm afraid to say that thought
that contingency will be voting for the
Republican ticket pretty much that's
that's what this statistics are
indicating that there's a lot of white
racist hatred out there that's going to
channel into a into a support for the
Republican ticket maybe in the false
belief that that these people are or
share their views I I don't think that
Trump pence are as racist as as the
people who attacked Leslie Jones I
really don't think you know from maybe
saying some things too
to go that way to get some votes but you
know I don't I don't well I don't know